cat videos have been filling up the
internet ever since it existed and they
have this wonderful mix of being aloof
and being super cute as well as being
conspiratorially evil if they want to so
are these lovable jerks actually trying
to do us harm
the classic internet
just having our dinner
that was a massive sprawling right are
cats scared of cucumbers let's get to
the bottom of it
now there's some conjecture out there
that a long thin thing could be like a
predator it could be a lizard could be a
snack
what are you going to imagine is that
they're like a superhero on four legs
they have amazing senses their wafties
are good their ear holes are awesome
their eyes are fantastic they've got
whiskers they can sense all around them
and then all of a sudden this cucumber
appears out of nowhere they've never had
anything appear out of nowhere that's
why they jump
laughs
should we continue to scare cats for our
enjoyment no we probably shouldn't
you're right ethically no but for
internet points yes
oh
[Music]
God they're like rebounding off every
surface as if it's like a pinball
machine
everybody's angry with each other
because none of them know what happened
oh you even get a good back arch and
fluffy tail at the end
[Music]
cats have incredibly fast reflexes
they're made up almost entirely of fast
twitch fibers they're sprinters a
domestic cat can jump up to nine times
its own body height so that would be
like the equivalent of me being able to
just jump straight up onto like the
third story of a building they have
incredibly flexible spines they can bend
every which way and that means that they
can parkour off like two surfaces at
once I told you they were superheroes
thank you
is that a pigeon she's going to Turf it
oh
one and gently just toss it why is she
asking it to fly backwards
I've nailed it the first chance it got I
mean to be fair they gave that cat every
advantage in that situation it's like
look at what we've got are you going to
eat this look at it it can't fly very
well
cats are incredible Hunters like
incredible hunters in Australia pet cats
are thought to kill
390 million native animals a year this
includes mammals birds and reptiles I
can hear you typing your next comment it
says my cat doesn't hunt because it
never brings anything home and I'm sorry
to say that that's probably because your
cat doesn't like you very much
there was a study out of America that
stated that about a quarter of all prey
items were bought home to the owner and
the rest of them were either consumed
out there in the big wide world or just
killed and left that's cats for you
oh cuttings
[Music]
Seether jump on that thing
that launched attack is pretty amazing
it jumped at least three times its own
height to attack him
this guy isn't a friend of these cats
he's a friend of their owner and he's
coming to clean up their poops
so number one maybe the cat is offended
that he's playing with the poops number
two it's an intruder and cats will
actually defend themselves and their
area
domestic cats are formidable animals
they've got front and back claws they
spend a lot of time looking after them
and making sure that they're absolutely
perfect murder mittens
number three the pants were frankly
offensive
in general Cats won't attack for no
reason but they can form you know some
testy relationships with individuals and
if you're on the receiving end of that
it may mean that your presence alone
will aggravate a cat holy sorry
[Music]
all right we got a kid on a bike
frankly looks a little bit too big for
the bike not judging
oh dog dog with tail up and erect dog
on a mission
yeah caddy oh look at it chased it away
and see that dog which you know
ostensibly could kill a cat quite easily
was scared of that cat that's
because cats are scary they also can be
loyal and protective and that's what
we're seeing from this cat the dog has
come at the child the cat was having
none of that the cat runs over and sees
the dog off using scare attack it comes
in sideways makes itself look bigger
it's got the big tail puffed out it was
using its claws and coming at the dog
and anyone who's been on the receiving
end of a cat claw knows that
ouch the dog takes off the cat makes
sure that it's gone and all of this is
to say that cats actually do have some
attachment to their owners
foreign
there's no doubt that cats will continue
to entertain us with their acrobatic
skills
and they're sometimes complex and quirky
behaviors
[Music]